[Musik]
Bosniens Wanderwege waren bis vor kurzem
noch vermiet erzählt mein Bergführer
sehr Rudin isakovic gefährliche Reste
der Jugoslawienkriege
seit knapp 30 Jahren ist Frieden die
Minen entschärft und wandern möglich
doch damals wie heute hat das
Weltgeschehen Einfluss auf den
Vielvölkerstaat besonders jetzt da
Wahlen an stehen erklärt mir der
Ex-Journalist besonders in
russlandfreundlichen Teil republikas
lipska
Russland wird jetzt immer aggressiver
versuchen den einen Landesteil die
bosnische Republik als rybza an sich zu
binden und so den Weg für das ganze Land
in Richtung EU zu versperren
gut
hier oben wirkt es wie Wahnsinn dass
sich nun die alten Konflikte zwischen
Serben Bosniaken und Kroaten wieder
verstärken gerade wenn man denkt man sei
fernab von einem holt einen
Bosnien-Herzegowina immer die
Vergangenheit wieder ein dies ist ein
alter Schützengraben
in Schützengräben scheinen manche
Politiker jeder Volksgruppe weiterhin zu
sitzen nationalistische Parolen
beherrschen die Wahl sie Rudin meint
dass soll er von echten Problemen
ablenken wieder wachsenden Armut
Politiker hetzen die Menschen mit
nationalistischer Rhetorik auf um sie
unter Kontrolle zu halten
das Ziel vor allem auf ihn sabbenführer
dodic sagt Muslime und Christen könnten
nicht zusammenleben er ist putinar
US-Geheimdienst der vermuten sogar
Geldflüsse
dodek will die republikasseepska
abspalten er will eine eigene Armee
eigene Waffen schmieden starke zeigen
damit will er Wähler gewinnen
wir besuchen die Waffenschmiede TRB in
der Republica sripska
erst seit wenigen Jahren produziert das
werkpistolen und Munition erzählt mir
die Geschäftsführerin miriana sharenaz
Micic ihr ganzer Stolz ist dies der
Despot
ein Militärfahrzeug mit Minenschutz
waffenstand und deutsche Motor so zeigt
es mir
jadrankastanimirovic was ist das
stärkste Verkaufsargument frage ich den
Ingenieur
es ist ein Design das sofort beeindruckt
auch mit seinen Dimensionen
soll der Name auch beeindrucken ja wenn
man die Bedeutung bedenkt das ist schon
beeindruckend
12 Tonnen Gewicht 130 Spitze rund 40
Liter Verbrauch das beeindruckt in der
Tat
dieses Auto fühlt sich an wie ein
fahrender Bunker
das Werbevideo wurde schon Interessenten
aus Afrika arabischen Ländern und
Russland gezeigt doch bisher kaufte nur
die Republica citipska 10 des Toten
Haupteigentümer der Firma ist Slawen
Ristic er kandidiert für die gleiche
Partei wie Serbenführer Dodik dazu will
sich die Geschäftsführerin lieber nicht
äußern aber trotzdem wird klar der
serbische Kraftprotz auf Rädern
verschafft Arbeit ansehen Einfluss
unser eigener glaubt an die Menschen
hier und er ist Patriot
unser eigener will das Leben besser
machen in dieser Stadt im ganzen Land
das tut dringend not
am Standort bratunuts ist die
Arbeitslosigkeit hoch
wer Arbeit will legt sich nicht mit der
Macht an die Bürger scheuen unser
Mikrofon nur manchmal bricht der Frust
heraus nichts wird hier besser sie
bezahlen uns für unsere Stimmen lass sie
das ruhig hören es ist alles gleich es
wird sich nichts ändern
und die nationalistische Propaganda
verfängt mindestens im Suff russland
werde uns in den Arsch treten sagt er
und ich bringe euch um
wir verlassen die Republica sripska
100 Kilometer weiter in Tuzla ist der
Spirit schon ganz anders schon immer
lebten hier alle Volksgruppen friedlich
zusammen die nationalistischen Töne im
Wahlkampf Regen vor allem in tusla auf
in der Universitätsstadt sind sie
multi-ethnisch und jung und hier regt
sich Widerstand
der Stadt in der Moschee katholische und
orthodoxe Kirche nebeneinander stehen
Karton Revolution spricht Klartext gegen
nationalistische Parolen für Klartext
kennt man sie auf dem Balkan
es spielt keine Rolle zu welchem Gott er
betet kapierste
Politik auf Social Media
Leila Adi Nedim und Adis wollen etwas
ändern auf Facebook und tiktok haben sie
tausende Follower und bis zu 1,9
Millionen Views bei ca 3 Millionen
Einwohnern im Land
es ist uns wichtig Unterstützung von
ganz Bosnien und hat sie kovina zu haben
denn nur die jungen Leute können etwas
ändern
viele junge Leute verlassen frustriert
dieses Land aber sie sprechen die Themen
an die ihre Generation interessieren
Korruption der regierenden Politiker
Umweltzerstörung
Vetternwirtschaft
der Druck auf Social Media wirkt bei
Treffen mit Politikern haben sie schon
kleine Gesetzesänderungen erreicht es
soll mehr werden jede Woche ein neues
Video jede Woche mehr Follower
um größere Veränderungen zu erreichen
brauchen wir mehr Leute die das wollen
keine Veränderungen sind wichtig um neue
Leute in die Politik zu bekommen
eine neue Generation will etwas ändern
sie wissen es braucht einen langen Atem
bald wollen sie selbst kandidieren
zunächst bei Lokalwahlen denn alle im
Land meinen es braucht Reformen aber
jeder meint damit etwas anderes eine
Wahlrechtsreform ist mal wieder
verschoben der Mann der sie vorschlug
der hohe un-beauftragte für das Land
verlor darauf schon mal die Beherrschung
hier manchmal muss es Klartext sein um
etwas zu bewegen erklärt mir Christian
Schmidt denn er hat große Pläne für
Bosnien und Herzegowina im Dezember
findet der nächste große europäische
Gipfel statt da wäre es gut wenn wir so
wie andere Länder Beitrittsverhandlungen
bekommen auch für Bosnien-Herzegowina
endlich den Kandidatenstatus bekommen
könnten
die Last der Vergangenheit oder der Weg
in eine bessere Zukunft was ist den
Menschen wichtiger das wird die Wahl
weisen
ein Blick auf die Hauptstadt Sarajevo
aber zeigt viel älter als die Spuren der
Konflikte sind die Zeugen für gutes
Miteinander
[Musik]